good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today is scp-1591
object class
header
special containment procedures
scp-1591 is to be contained at area 79
within a containment vault 100 meters
below the surface level
scp-1591 is to be placed in the center
of this vault with 30 high intensity
spotlights arranged in a 1 meter
circular pattern above below and around
it once every month the spotlights are
to be replaced by d-class personnel due
to the damage caused by
scp-1591's effect an equivalent set of
spotlights are to be kept in position
outside the vault in case of containment
procedures failing or being enacted
incorrectly
a research and development team
headquartered within area 79 is
completely dedicated to developing and
engineering the increasingly advanced
containment light mechanisms and
maintaining the electrical
infrastructure necessary to continue
scp-1591's containment materials from
scp
have been implemented as part of their
research and use of other objects is
under consideration
photosensitive broadcasting units are to
be set up above below and around the
vault to monitor for a containment
breach if any photosensitive
broadcasting units cease to function
surface teams are to prepare 75 high
intensity spotlights with an intensity
600 000 lumens greater than scp-1500
intensity to cease the expansion of
scp-1591's effect in the event that
containment is breached o5 command is to
be alerted to the possibility of an
xk-class end-of-the-world scenario
description
scp-1591 is a glass sculpture in the
shape of a star surrounded by 14 sheets
of stained glass the central sculpture
weighs 1.2 kilograms with the individual
panels weighing 12 kilograms each all
components of scp-1591 are suspended
approximately 6 meters above the ground
through an as yet unknown mechanism to
date efforts to affect the levitation of
either the sculpture or the panels have
been unsuccessful
scp-1591
constantly produces light with gradually
increasing brightness and intensity any
surface illuminated by scp-1590
will appear to become inconsistently
transparent and if not removed any
affected matter will disappear from
observable space non-solid matter that
makes contact with light produced by
scp-1591
will begin to rapidly decrease in
temperature until it takes on a solid
form
scp-1591 is immune to its own effect
organisms will retain consciousness and
mobility while being affected by scp-15
although the ability to create speech
will be lost affected organisms will
usually react in a panicked manner
attempting to flee from
scp-1591's light as quickly as possible
if an affected organism ceases being
exposed to
scp-1591's light it will quickly fade
and vanish further research of this
effect has been inhibited by the
continued destruction of observational
equipment scp-1591
being exposed to lights with a greater
intensity than its own will cause the
rate at which its brightness increases
to be reduced by 10 000 lumens to 50 000
lumens every 24 hours the intensity of
the light produced by scp-1591
does not decrease over distance
scp-1591 was recovered in 1940 from
italy where it was in the position of
known serpent's hand operatives during
initial containment
scp-1591's effect was negligible taking
over 82 hours to completely destroy a
three by four by three meter wooden
block it was contained within site-77's
safe containment wing focusing light on
scp-1591 was discovered to prevent its
effect from spreading initially the
light required for containment of
scp-1591
was relatively low
in february of 1941 site-77 was
partially damaged by allied bombing
raids these bombs caused
scp-1591's containment to be breached
resulting in most of the remaining
portions of site-77 being destroyed
after control of the facility was
re-established
scp-1591 was discovered to be
significantly more hazardous and
reclassified as euclid a second
containment breach resulted in site-77
being severely damaged and the loss of
personnel
addendum 519 1941.
several documents relating to
scp-1591 were recovered by mobile task
force sigma-3 bibliographers from a
location inhabited by members of the
serpent's hand these included
photographs diagrams and documents one
example has been included in this report
playing log now
war with elric
we had been at peace for almost
568 years but they had decided to
declare war upon us the verderers tried
to assure us that we would be defended
safe from the king's wrath
killed
all killed
i saw
little boys strung up by their backs
snapping in half as they were wrenched
upwards towards the stars women were
struck down in the streets
lanced and stabbed until they begged to
die
men who fought back were blinded and
made lame then displayed proudly in shop
windows
my mother was shaved boiled and eaten by
a pillaging group of warriors it was
pure decimation far beyond what had been
necessary to bring vengeance to their
kingdom when the heavens saw this they
cast their eyes away disgusted
by the el richian carnage
the heavens cast themselves to earth
they could not stand to watch any longer
and soon
they were falling every moment first
only on our lands
then on theirs bringing in
even worse carnage than what we had
suffered i could smell the burning from
the northern provinces
this star is a gift to you from heaven
in the right hands it will be a tool to
bring downed senselessness but do not
forget its origin if the hatred and
carnage once again reach its light it
will cast down purity wiping it from
your lands
the stars are beautiful tonight
the stars have started to come out i can
see them through the cracks in the
ceiling used to be that on nights like
this i'd be in the eastern tower
watching them i had one of those brass
telescopes that the academy uses with
knobs on the right side in the crooked
stand grandfather had imported it from
chang zhao for my 11th birthday only the
heavens know how he was able to get a
trader to land that far off
that telescope was
something else i was able to see the
image of all the stars on the horizon
there were big stars little stars flashy
stars and the distant objects that
grandfather told me were moons and
planets many nights would end with me
fast asleep in front of it a celestial
book in my lap and a pudgy young face
resting against the viewing piece
grandfather said that these weren't
really stars just the images the
memories of how they looked long past it
was an honor he said to be able to gaze
upon such storied history
i remember one night grandfather took me
out to the courtyard to watch the stars
fall
it was beautiful they danced and twirled
through the sky a seemingly endless
supply of brilliance and color they
flashed and pulsed with light as if they
had been waiting for me to put on a show
although i begged him for months and
months we never went out there again
even if it was only one trip
the image of the stars frolicking
swiftly throughout the cosmos has stayed
ingrained in my mind
when i became head of the castle there
was no more nonsense like that
i was grown up and there was to be no
funny business on my watch
i made sure my son was given the
greatest education in the land and given
tutelage in the widest birth of material
but for the study of the cosmos we
learned with each other he and i would
crowd around that dusty old telescope
keeping close watch on the heavens and
their constellations
i miss him now more than ever
when he was lost to the family the
entire nation seemed to grieve all my
defenders were sent to search
and when he was found broken and still
at the border there were no words
that could describe my grief i was
despairing and in this state i demanded
retribution the defenders took up my
banner and we attacked those we believed
to have wronged us
we ravaged them with our hate destroying
every man woman and child we felt
justice had been done
but the heavens did not smile as we
smote our enemy
they saw us driving them from their
lands and slaughtering them in greater
number than it ever been seen
it was too much to bear the heavens had
descended upon us first in small number
then greater so many stars that i had
once seen flittering about the vast
frontiers came down to us breaking
everything we held the flashing of light
could be seen for many miles when they
fell and we found ourselves suffering a
worse fate than our tormentors
i do not know why i have been spared
perhaps to serve as a living legacy to
the folly of my kingdom or perhaps to
bear witness to the end of a dynasty
when the time comes i will go to the
tower one last time
and look over the vast emptiness of land
i once ruled
the stars look beautiful tonight
and log
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
anvil
aletreon
derivative
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
tailored printers
clad the lad
perpetually confused meat tech pilot
signar
your local foundation agent
gabriel hawkins
nate the clown
lost boy
a real american hebrew
sayo dio damnares
eric corbige
longinus
the morrigan
karim el ashmuy
james saba
and
nj bojack if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos and some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you